des rangées de citoyens attendent
l'injection de leurs premières doses de
vaccin
cela peut paraître anodin dans le
contexte actuel de la crise mais en
tunisie cela représente une lueur
d'espoir en pleine quatrième bague
particulièrement meurtrières dans le
palais des congrès de tunis transformé
pour l'occasion en bacs cynodrome la
fréquentation est toujours aussi forte
pour le personnel soignant le rythme est
soutenu le geste précis
objectif se rassurer vacciner et
sensibiliser calme et où les gens
arrivent stressés
certains ont peur de se faire piquer
mais nous sommes là pour les rassurer
je suis heureuse que nous puissions
enfin vacciner massivement la population
le don aux colosses grâce aux dons et à
la journée nationale de la vaccination
qui a été décrétée par le président
depuis samedi
on n'arrête pas plus de 1500 personnes
par jour suite à l'appel du président
sayyed à une journée nationale de la
vaccination samedi dernier plus de 500
mille doses ont été administrées sur
l'ensemble du territoire grâce aux
nombreux dons venus des quatre coins du
globe
la campagne de vaccination enfin pu
décoller de quoi rassurer les tunisiens
toujours plus nombreux à venir se faire
vacciner
je travaille dans le tourisme il fallait
que je me vaccine afin de pouvoir
continuer à travailler
en plus je suis marié j'ai deux enfants
il fallait que je me vaccine pour me
protéger et protéger ma famille je suis
très heureuse c'est merveilleux de
pouvoir se faire vacciner afin de
protéger sa famille c'est la raison pour
laquelle je suis là aujourd'hui
j'espère que grâce à cela la situation
va s'améliorer
soulagement
c'est un soulagement
et depuis ce centre je voudrais dire à
tout le monde de s'inscrire rapidement
sur la plateforme et vax et d'aller se
faire vacciner le plus rapidement
possible soit disant mail qu'ils avaient
capturé
wismond le veuille ou non on ne pourra
sortir de cette crise que par la
vaccination
il faudrait que 70% de la population
soit vaccinée pour pouvoir atteindre
l'immunité collective une unité général
chaque m
depuis plusieurs semaines en plus des
crises politiques économiques et
sociales qui secoue le pays
la tunisie fait face à une grave selon b
de l'épidémie lenteur du rythme de la
vaccination et manque de doses ont
généré une explosion des contaminations
selon le dernier bilan officiel les cas
confirmés de kobe 19 ont dépassé le
seuil des 600 mille cas les autorités
déplore pas moins de 20000 931 décès la
campagne de vaccination bat son plein en
tunisie après les nombreux dons de dos
qui ont afflué ces dernières semaines
des quatre coins de la planète samedi
plus d'un million de doses de vaccin
contre le coronavirus ont été
administrées dans le cadre d'une
accélération de la campagne nationale de
vaccination afin d'enrayer la
propagation de l'épidémie si à ce jour
plus de 14% de la population étaient
vaccinés la tunisie espère vacciner
environ 50 % de ses habitants d'ici à la
mi octobre